this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death lurks around every corner
I am so ready Justin you obviously
understood the assignment because when I
saw this trailer I have not seen the
movie I was like oh my gosh so many
little fun Easter eggs in there but what
I cannot believe is that you actually
worked at Disney this was your summer
job this is the ultimate in
manifestation or or Serendipity or but
was there anything from that experience
as a team that you actually brought into
directing this film yeah I mean for me
uh I wish I was a teen it was a little
bit later I was in film School actually
and uh I felt one very nerdy for being
that excited about working at Disneyland
uh it was very I was very different from
my other like film school peers in that
way but there was such a there's
something so immersive about the way
those rides are built and the Haunted
Mansion is one of those rides and I was
just like every time I walk past this
one step I get goosebumps it's like
clockwork it's a kind of Storytelling
that like I was so excited to figure out
a way to like come up with a cinematic
equivalent to because it's it's it's its
own thing and there's nothing like it in
in the world what was a step oh gosh so
for me I mean for me in the Haunted
Mansion is of course when you get locked
in that first room and the stretching
room when you start to stress it's like
I you just really feel like you're in a
different place they they so completely
take you outside of reality and I just
think that was right you haven't seen
the movie I haven't seen the movie
and that that especially I mean the
movie is great everything you've done
you captured I mean you Blended the
humanity in the ride but that scene in
the in the strut in the that that's the
one that we always remember when we walk
into the Haunted Mansion and and the
first time I've been there dozens of
times because I have three kids uh it
did Park but when that when those walls
start going and everything starts
perspective changing man you really did
you you knocked that one out of the park
where's our you're clapping you all have
the rest of you've all seen the movie so
how amazing is is it how I mean it's
like unhinged just the word in the
trailer for the house
is this movie The thing about it is it's
scary but it's you know you get the
individuality with with Justin's good at
and a lot of things he's good at but in
that idea of allowing the characters to
come through I mean you really get the
feeling of the house and that is like
because when we went there it was
immense that thing was big you know you
can believe it but but what comes
through in the film is everybody's
individual character who have all kinds
of problems that kind of meld together
and synergistically in the ultimate like
experience of the Haunted Mansion I like
what you did there with the
coming through that was
very good
it's funny yeah and you'll have fun yeah
like I'm not always the biggest fan of
scary movies because I want to like I
want to laugh but I also don't want to
be like scared scared but it's like
scary enough
where it don't make you like oh I gotta
close my eyes but just like ah I can't
be present for this and I feel Joy in my
heart while they're going through all
this yeah I felt a lot of Joy personally
what is everybody's favorite ghost in
the film because there's 999 haunts in
the ride I want to know from you Justin
how many haunts are there in the film
and from the rest of the cast your
favorite ghost in the film well they're
exactly 999 in the film no I don't know
I gotta say for me is the Mariner goes
like I don't know why there's something
about that painting uh there's something
about uh being lost at sea that just
kind of speaks to me
um and uh and I felt like look I think
this movie is a lot of things it's a
ride but it's also about this man this
young man who is moving through
something kind of emotional and his
ability to feel his feelings is what
this movie hinges on and you know the
sea and water and being lost as sea is
such a beautiful I think visual metaphor
for like feelings and tough feelings and
I don't know it's like there's a moment
when when the kid's character Ben locks
eyes with the Mariner and and that's
that moment for me is like kind of how I
felt in this process it's like there's
something we're channeling here that's
just a little bit special you know yeah
I'm a big fan of um things that are true
to Source material and I I I you know I
experienced the ride because that's what
it is it's an experience it really is
you or it's unlike any other ride I
think it's it's it's real fun to go
through so seeing that that the story
that I was given paid close attention to
detail in that way it really excited me
because I don't I don't enjoy seeing
things that aren't the same as the the
thing that I enjoy but at the same time
uh to Justin's point there was rich deep
storytelling and characters that were
compelling and the way that that was
able to be merged and married together
was unique and I hadn't read it in a
script in a while so it was it was
really profound to come across this and
it is it feels unsettling in just the
the right way and I appreciate Disney
for taking a step to do something
different different in terms of the
storytelling in terms of the casting in
terms of the director this is a fresh
new take on something completely
different than the original
um and we're grateful for the original
but this is something that stands as its
own beast and I'm really happy to have
it and then sparring with people like
Danny and Owen oh my gosh the scene with
the two of you with the police sketch
and Danny your impression of the Hat Box
Ghost with the lip I'm gonna do it I
know my mom did the impression you know
what I mean even doing that impression
my mom did it the other day I was like
just based off of the trailer such an
amazing scene what about you favorite
ghost my favorite ghost is the horse
yeah I like the horse you know and me
being a unicorn and all I just really
can relate to the horse yeah
oh yeah I forgot my favorite ghost is
also the Mariner it is when you walk
that was there right
right I do like the metaphors of the
ocean and being like water today I was
like I had like my nerves were a little
you know starting with with pressing
everything and my friend was like be
like water and it reminded me how water
is such a metaphor for so many things
and it's scary feelings yeah they flow
like you're scary man I don't like to be
on the water
oh yeah it's scary you get into a storm
that was like what like we you captured
in the movie basically you're in a you
know there's a scene that we won't talk
about because you're gonna go see the
movie but there's a storm scene in this
damn movie I mean that is big and that's
like you know you look at uh if you've
ever seen like
ships out in the sea or or you know oil
rigs being bashed by the ocean water
scary as hell I want to say where it was
at but I'm not going to say it because
you've got to go see the movie to find
out but my favorite there's a couple big
jumps in the movie but one of them was
that that damn bride
you know I mean that that was like that
was scary and there's some weird looking
people in it it is a weird looking
ghosts I mean you know like with Owen
they look like they're understanding him
but they don't give a damn
[Laughter]
that could be the catchphrase for the
movie The Ghost they don't give a damn
Daniel you're in there they don't give
them that
I mean I saw the movie at 10 o'clock in
the morning and ended up calling
everyone to just gush about the
chemistry and the energy and just the
how just perfectly they embodied their
characters they're such brilliant
moments of just growth and development
and like nuances to each of these
characters in the midst of all of this
story that was like can be really
emotional and suddenly pivot very funny
there's this very striking scene with
you know the Keith talking about these
memories and it gets super emotional I'm
literally starting to tear up wow and
then you cut to his face and his
reaction to the story and you're like
how are we going from crying to laughing
like this and you've got jump scares and
all kinds of stuff that go on so the
movie is just it's a ride it feels like
a ride and and I think that you know
talking about making that interpretation
of the feeling of being in it you know
this was Walt Disney's I think one of
the last rides that he ever approved of
it didn't even go into use until I think
two out two years after his passing and
it's so interesting reading about the
history of it because there was such a
fight internally about like how scary do
you make it or how funny and spooked
like is it scary or spooky and what you
know what that line is and I think you
know Justin you did just a brilliant job
of like holding that line throughout the
entire film and so it's it's great and
so for me the ax bride is the same for
me you know because we did a lot of
stuff practically
so you know these are folks who are
running around with prosthetics on and
these incredible costumes that Jeffrey
did and you know it's just looked so
cool on the day but then like millions
of dollars later when you add all the
special effects to add it to actually
have them flying around and that ax
flying through the room it's scary like
it's like it went from you know it was
so it's just a great balance like I it
was really thrilling and I was just
laughing about how I had a great time I
had watching this movie at 10 am and I
will ask only you you have Ahsoka coming
out another Disney project your favorite
Force ghost
oh my goodness
um I mean I think that's got to be uh
that's got to be Anakin for me just
because I I'm looking at the history of
it he didn't even know that's what he
was filming apparently and they threw it
in so he's all Smiley and stuff and they
just put it into the movie and he
apparently didn't know that and was like
oh if I had known I would have portrayed
it a little differently but he just like
caught like I guess George just got this
extra scene of him and just sort of
threw him in there which I just think is
kind of amazing so I like the very
reluctant
you know very reluctant Force ghost
um I want to ask you about acting
opposite Jamie Lee Curtis's head as
Madame Leona I mean Jamie look at
Curtis's head right off he'd like to
bring her in
but we got her head so that's all we
could afford yeah
I think Justin said that you two were
like the most unexpected Duo together so
how did that sort of work on the day I
know you shot a lot practically like did
was she sort of like under a table with
you know CG afterwards or how did that
work it was like she was in a chair and
then she had to like be really still
here it was Rosario and I like that was
like feeding her lines Justin was
feeding her lines too and I think we all
wanted the opportunities we acted
directly with Jamie Lee yeah
coming back up like this like
it's like for eye lines for stuff we
were so excited we were doing a lot it
was the best and she's so funny so fun
and so easy to talk to and then her and
Danny were telling me the best stories
of the day we were doing the green
screen stuff
and we can't repeat those stories
a lot of money for those stories but I
got to get paid to listen to them and
that's how I think of it anyways uh and
it was a lot of fun she's so awesome and
she returns text messages and she's an
Oscar winner I forgot to enter to say
Oscars right that's right that's right
Justin what a cast you assembled for
this movie I I wonder if you've ever
seen the Met Gala of Jared Leto carrying
his own head up the red carpet because
it's very happy of course I've seen it
is that why you cast him in this film
honestly How deep did he go also because
he loves to be unrecognizable and
everything I promise you if you did not
know specifically that this was Jared
Leto you would never guess who it was
okay like like one of the things about
the movie and and Rosario talked about
this already is like the ride has this
quality where you know something you
know a trick has to be played here but
you cannot quite spot the edges you
can't quite figure out how they're doing
it and and the hatbox ghost character is
very much that you it's it's part man
it's part you know CGI it's part
practical and the voice is just
incredible but there's he comes he
literally transforms uh in this
particular role and for you how many
because I can just tell even just by the
the footage and the trailer I've seen
how many Easter eggs you put in this I
know Disney gave you the Bible they took
you behind the scenes of the ride can
you tease like an Easter egg or
something that you were like I have to
put in this book honestly like
everything I could because I'm a you
know I'm a fanboy like I come from that
fandom culture okay and especially with
something like this I was like it only
gets richer the truer we are to the
source because the source is inspired
like you were saying like there was a
fight to figure out what the tone of
this thing should be and that fight that
tension creates something really magical
about it so I mean everything down to
like the paintings that were gone and
then came back into the ride like I was
like clocking in those like okay we got
to put that in a prominent spot
everything down to the doorknobs okay
the way the the doors are framed
certainly the wallpaper had to be right
the ghost had to be right and the other
thing that I wanted to bring to it is
like a real sense of cultural uh
culturally being really placed in New
Orleans like it was really important to
me that like you know we say this house
is in New Orleans New Orleans is a very
black City and it has many different
cultures that come together and mix and
and find this kind of Harmony together
and I absolutely wanted to infuse you
know that sort of authenticity into the
ride too I want to tell ghost stories
because I think I'm uniquely qualified
to do this interview because there's a
moment like Keith where your character
has a ghost possess him in the trailer
and goes through his body and this
actually happened to me in Tokyo where I
was like I literally had a ghost pass
through my body I'm not crazy I I wasn't
okay we're done with this
so I'm wondering if any of you have had
a haunting an encounter a go story I'm
going to start with you Danny
don't start with me please I God I am a
ghost
I'm haunting you all
if I told you my ghost stories
I would probably just disappear right
now because the ghosts
I can't say okay I can't even talk about
them there wow wow this is getting real
yeah they make him signed a ghosting
it's even worse than that it's not even
yeah it can't even it's not yeah it's
like you can't well I love the uh the
metaphor for soul reaping something that
me and Justin talked about early on that
Ben is on this journey to find himself
find his soul he's going through
mourning at the beginning of the story
and he has to sort of reposition himself
in life and find his feet after a
terrible loss and it's a difficult thing
for a lot of us to deal with identify
with that struggle and navigating the
harder moments in life to try and find
your your true self and so he had to
give up some things that no longer
served him to let in things that did
serve them so he could find himself and
be the person he wanted to be that at
the center of the story was really
important for me this is not
just like cheesy scary ghosts this is a
real meaningful story embedded in in
this in this film and that is what
really drew me to it in the beginning
and all of the little Trinkets and
treats and ghosts in VFX is all just
serving that Center story that that
serves as the spine and that's something
I really appreciate well I will end on a
meaningful question then there is a line
in the trailer that you say are you sure
you want to enter this house because it
will change your life and I'm sure as
actors every step that you enter changes
your life in some way so I'm wondering
how this experience of working together
and working on this unique film changed
you as performers
well they just get to be seen
well I'm a lot more patient now and I am
psychic I'm a Tarot reader check my tick
tocks out
I knew that was coming plug
Tiffany haddish it made me better I was
going through a personal transition in
my life where I was just really working
on my spirit and my soul asking these
like questions to myself about things
that I needed to unpack and working on
this film gave me the opportunity to be
focused on something that was important
that I felt was important that I had to
show up for every day and sort of rally
all the troops together and work with
these really talented people who I grew
up watching like like Danny and Jamie
Lee Curtis coming in someone who's a
really good spiritual beautiful person
if you get to know her you'll learn that
Rosario who's always a perfect example
of how to maintain balance in yourself I
don't know how she's always in such a
good mood it's a beautiful thing and
Tiffany who's always reminding you to
laugh and just you know stay jovial and
you know just just really have fun in
the process and so I couldn't be more
thankful for the group of people that I
was with love Danny I mean he just I
invite him to my parties now I think the
thing is that it it you know this is
like been said a million times but you
know you have a fearless leader and that
was Justin and you have people who are
really are dedicated uh besides Justin
who is totally immersed in this and we
all are we you know give ourselves over
to that sometimes you give yourself over
to the wrong person we give ourselves
over to the right person we were very
fortunate to have him also we have the
technology the people who did the the
the Jeffrey uh uh curl and forget about
it his costumes are off the charts but
but there's another Jeffrey Jeffrey the
DP
incredible who's whose work is like
magnificent in the movie and so that
combination it's always said to be a
collaborative art everybody's together
in it and besides the fact that we've
become a family only the cast and that I
attribute to the director always uh am I
cooking and you're cooking oh right
those men I'm telling you that was like
whenever whenever she's cooking I'm
there baby I'm telling you and so all
that whole combination in this film in
in uh really worked very well and and
we'll all remember it forever yeah yeah
I mean for me it was like you know I had
come off of several projects that had
been very very intense a lot of ugly
crying and and I literally just put out
into the universe like I need to do a
comedy or something and then this showed
up and I just couldn't believe it and
then I'm with some of the funniest
people to ever exist on this planet and
was super intimidated but I have this
amazing young man in Chase who's playing
my son and we would have these scenes
where you know a lot of the times we're
watching these experts that we brought
into this house to help us try to do
their thing and the just the chemistry
between everybody and the fun of it all
and we would just be throwing our looks
to each other and just to see it play in
there and stretch myself because I don't
do comedy very often and it was just
really fun to kind of relax more you
know and play this very still very
tightly woven up kind of character and
just I just love the balance of her I
loved how strong she was I loved how
kitschy and weird and specific she was
and you know and I just really loved how
everyone jumped into their roles in that
way and just to be on set every day just
taking in people's process because
including when we watched Jamie Jamie's
there with dots on her face and just
doing this performance over and over and
over again this huge monologue that
she's doing and would just you'd give a
tiny little adjustment of a tonal shift
and it would be completely different and
it was just mesmerizing we'd be sitting
there staring at her and then go all
right we're supposed to be working with
us all right let's get it but it was
just like a notes all day after felt
like I was taking notes all the time
they know how many pictures I was taking
on set watching between him and Owen
fighting was like one of the most
hysterical things to ever witness in
life I was like yes please
um it just was really great and so I
just definitely want to shout out to
chase because he really is such a huge
heart in this film and what a remarkable
young man and performance level and how
just I mean I felt intimidated at times
showing up upset and like really holding
myself I mean here's this child who is
not a child he's like a grown man in
this child's body and just holding his
own and like totally fearless and it was
exactly that kind of energy that needed
to happen with all of us we had it we
had to become more Fearless together as
a family in order to to have any kind of
Triumph and it was it was great to find
that with each other and he had a growth
spurt during the film he did it was so
his voice started changing we were like
he's like up here to me we're like this
house is going to work I'm like stop it
same note to chase was like remember
you're nine
funniest scenes ever is he supposed to
play with these action figures and he's
like what do we do and you're like what
do you mean what do you do play with him
he's like I've never played with these
they're like not shocked by that
whatsoever but we're gonna need you to
figure it out do some research he's an
old soul so he was perfect for this
fellow I would let his fearless leader
have the last word about how this
changed you as an artist oh my gosh this
was like my first movie
I made it in 19 days with less than a
million dollars okay so to go from that
to something like this where I think we
shot for like I don't know 150 billion
days I'm not sure
um realizing that the job is exactly the
same but the scale uh is quite different
and the kinds of things that you have to
balance are very different and I felt
like I was ready for it but at the same
time I feel like I had to grow so much
every single day working on this project
I mean it's like a it I can't even I
couldn't have imagined the person I had
to become to complete this film when I
started it and uh and that's like Danny
said that's something that like I'll
take with me forever I'm a different
director now uh having made this film
and for the better